Welcome to EmacsCons 2024, where we have fun exploring how much we can do with a text
editor.
It's hard to give a general overview of all the cool talks today and tomorrow, so you
can flip through the talks and see what sparks your interests.
Don't feel limited to one track or another.
The best parts of EmacsCons are the conversations.
The Wiki has a page on how to watch and participate, and I'll give you a quick overview as well.
You can watch both streams at live.emacsCons.org using free and open source software.
Having a streaming media player like MPV seems to be the best way to watch in terms of performance,
but there are also web-based players just in case that's all you've got.
The schedule shows the general track on top and the development track on the bottom, so you
can see what else is going on.
As you're watching the talks, you can refer to the schedule in another window, hover
over the boxes to see the times and titles, and click on the boxes in the schedule to jump
to the talks page for more details.
You can also get the schedule as an eye calendar file or as an org file in different time zones.
Many talks will be followed by live Q&A web conferences with a speaker, which will be done
in big blue button or BBB.
These are indicated with a solid border on the schedule and by Q&A BBB on the schedule
page.
You can join the web conference room by clicking on the BBB link on the schedule page or
the talks web page.
Then you can ask your questions yourself when the Q&A starts.
To improve performance, please keep your webcam off and stay muted until it's your turn
to talk.
If you don't like JavaScript, you can still ask questions via IRC, and the hosts can read
them out for you.
We're probably going to automatically switch between talks and Q&A sessions, so the transitions
on the stream might be a little sudden.
People in the big blue button room can continue the conversation even after the talk moves
off stream, and you can also reach out to the speakers using the contact information
on the talk page.
Other talks will have Q&A via either pad or IRC depending on what the speakers prefer.
This is indicated in the schedule with a dashed border and on the schedule page as well.
As an experiment, the Q&A for them a Clim talk this afternoon will also be in Lamb Demo.
If you'd like to try it out, see them a Clim talk page for instructions so you can join
the discussion there.
The schedule pages and track pages have quick shortcuts so that you can find out more
about talks, open the either pads, and join the Q&A sessions.
The watch page has more tips on how to make the most of Q&A.
If you can, please add notes and ask questions in the either pad for the talk, that makes it
easier for everyone to share their notes, and speakers and hosts can read the questions
from there.
We'll copy the notes to the talk pages afterwards.
We have one pad for each talk, so you can follow the links to get to the next one or go
back to the schedule and get the link from there.
If you have general feedback about the conference itself, please put it in pad.emaxclons.org/20204, which
is linked in each pad.
You can also use this as a general community message board for things like help wanted.
Internet really chat or IRC can be another great way to be part of lots of conversations.
You can use chat.emaxclons.org to join the IRC channels through your web browser.
The tabs in the left can help you switch between the different channels.
There's emaxclons.gen for the general track and emaxclons.dev for the development track.
If you need to reach us, you can join emaxclons.org or email emaxclons.org/private@gnau.org.
You can use emaxclons for hallway conversations.
Of course you can join any of these channels with your favorite IRC client by connecting to
irc.libera.chat/port6697 using TLS.
Once again we're going to be streaming with open captions for most of the talks this year.
Thanks for speakers and captioning volunteers.
The caption talks are indicated on the schedule and with any luck we'll be posting transcripts
and talk pages shortly after the talk start.
If you need additional accommodations, please let us know in emaxclons.org and we'll see
if it can make things happen.
If something goes down, we'll update status.emaxclons.org.
If it doesn't look like we've noticed yet, please let us know in the emaxclons.org IRC
channel where we will be quietly panicking.
In all of these conversations, please keep in mind our guidelines for conduct.
You can find them on the wiki, they basically boil down to, please be nice.
If all goes well, the prerequisite of the talks and transcripts should be available from
the talk pages shortly after they start playing.
And we'll post the recordings of live talks and Q&A sessions within the next month or so.
If you'd like to get an update, you can subscribe to the emaxclons.gov/discussmailinglist.
Alright, let's get going.
Leo is hosting the channel track and Karwin is hosting the development track.
The other volunteers tonight will run around mostly backstage and you'll probably meet us
in the closing remarks.
That's also where we get to thank all the people and organizations who make emaxclons possible.
Thanks for coming to emaxclons 2024.